14 of americans now own bitcoin or
crypto currencies bank of america has
released a new 140-page report covering
digital asset industry including nfts
installing institutional investments and
the rates of growth it's called the
global cryptocurrencies and digital
assets reports digital asset primer in
brief only the first inning they've got
enough authors on here to fill out an
entire baseball team but by the numbers
it's estimated that 21.2 million u.s
adults own digital assets about 14
of us adults own digital assets they
believe that another 13 plan to buy in
2021 that would bring us to a total of
27 percent of the united states
population will use our own
cryptocurrencies before the end of the
year
now on top of that they say that there
are over 200 million crypto users
globally there are now 11 500 plus
altcoins or tokens outside of bitcoin
although many do not have a clear use
case they are incredibly bullish in this
report they say we are only in the first
innings of a major change in
applications across most industries that
will take place over the next 30 years
so kind of a multi-decade outlook here
from bank of america the estimates
indicate that 221 million users globally
as of june 2021 have traded a
cryptocurrency or used a blockchain
based application which is up from 66
million at the end of may 2020 and then
also the second point is that due to
technological advances in decentralized
software that is native to the internet
a new medium with distributed ledgers
and blockchains at its core it is
emerging rapidly and so when we think
about this 14 as of june of u.s
population own cryptocurrency but they
believe that that will jump all the way
up to 27 of us adults will own
cryptocurrencies before the end of the
year that is a big number but not very
surprising when you start to look at the
numbers like a coinbase which has over
55 million registered users the bigger
number to me and the more surprising
numbers that they estimate now over 220
million people globally own crypto
assets or have used blockchain-based
applications that seems like a really
really big number and so when you see a
large organization like a bank of
america going out and putting in a ton
of work creating a report like this and
releasing it and being ultra bullish you
have to think that over the next couple
of decades we are likely to see a
drastic increase in the adoption of
these assets more participation from the
legacy system and also if you see an
increase in adoption and an increase in
institutional participation it will
likely lead to prices of various assets
and various technologies continuing to
appreciate for years to come what was
the most surprising part of this report
to you john
um the fact that they said 14 use it now
i wasn't surprised by that number i was
surprised that they said this report was
released earlier this week that 13
more people will hold digital assets uh
us adults will hold digital assets by
the end of the year basically right the
report said in 2021. so it was a little
bit surprising to me that within a
three-month span or whenever they
started working on this report that we
are actually going to double the amount
of people of u.s adults that hold
digital assets that was the most
surprising and obviously bank of america
is very bullish on bitcoin and very
bullish on cryptocurrency
joe what do you think
yeah i think uh what's surprising me is
kind of what's been happening over the
last week or so right when you look at
uh bitcoin has traditionally
moved alongside other risk assets right
when you look at kind of the the four
five six seven year history here uh
there's obviously been some booms cycles
some bull markets and bear markets et
cetera and it hasn't been kind of a
perfect outlay but especially over the
last couple of years it's it's been
moving alongside traditional risk assets
assets and over the last one to two
weeks it's really decoupled from that
right so if you look at everything
that's happening in the equity markets
and kind of the other markets uh in
finance bitcoin is moving outside of
that so we have a bunch of uh jobs
aren't growing as fast the unemployment
rate is high inflation is bad uh you
know all these things that there's
regulatory uncertainty covett is
stalling and people aren't going back to
work all this stuff right has put equity
markets in kind of a standstill over the
last few weeks bitcoin's up 25 this
month we're what we're eight days in
right so when you look at it kind of
it's out performance it's done really
well over the last month uh and then i
think if you look at it from kind of
the adoption that we're seeing
it's obvious that 2017 uh 2020 and going
forward it's not just kind of fear or
fomo or people trying to get rich or
people trying to uh realize profits all
this stuff and chasing all that there's
real adoption uh that's happening both
in the institutional world and the
retail world countries have it as legal
tender there's a bunch of other stuff
going on but i think the main thing to
realize is that like this isn't going
anywhere right like the saying i believe
is just bitcoin is inevitable and when
you look at it from kind of the adoption
numbers that legacy banks are now
putting out and all these other
institutions are saying hey look this is
going to grow by a lot over the next
short time period but also over the long
run a bunch of people are going to adopt
these assets a bunch of people are going
to hold them personally i think what
we're going to see is that massive price
appreciation continue and i wouldn't be
surprised if uh if we get further and
further away and decouple ourselves
further from traditional risk assets
like equities
john
what do you think about that at what
point in time do you think that we get
more uncorrelated with the other
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin in general
and then um equities as well i think the
decoupling is only going to continue for
for quite a while here but it all feeds
together right if you think about if you
zoom out for a second here is like the
the um uh here's like the macro view of
what's happening in the world right now
you have technology as a deflationary
force part of the reason why there's 11
million open jobs there's high
unemployment et cetera is because
technology is driving the cost of labor
down drastically it's actually allowing
businesses to do more with less human
labor right so you have this massive
technology uh force that drives down
deflation on top of that you have
politicians who now are essentially the
drivers of fiscal monetary policy when
they tell people to jump they jump and
so what they're incentivized to do is
mitigate short-term pain if all of a
sudden we are going through a transition
from lots of human labor needed to do
tasks to now replacing that with
technology you then have humans that are
displaced from their jobs that
short-term pain politicians will not
allow to occur because it's bad for
business it doesn't get you reelected if
your people are suffering so what they
do then is they use both their direct
powers and indirect influence to get the
treasury the federal reserve and other
organizations to go ahead and
participate in the devaluation of the
currency the entire idea is we can
basically borrow a bunch of debt which
is a complete ponzi scheme in terms of
borrowing more debt to pay off earlier
debt then on top of that what we can do
is we can continue to devalue that
currency we will hand out direct
stimulus we'll manipulate interest rates
we'll do everything we can to keep
kicking the can down the road but what
ultimately occurs is that while it feels
good in the short term to give somebody
money a 1200 stimulus check it actually
hurts them over the next 18 36 or five
months or five years because what they
really start to see is then they get
high inflation so right now if you look
over the last 18 months what happened
was there was a public health crisis it
drove economic slowdown that economic
slowdown led to short-term pain
short-term pain was addressed by
politicians and central bankers they
stepped in they intervened in the market
manipulated interest rates down to zero
they printed trillions of dollars they
handed some of that money directly to
people they also handed it directly to
corporations and they also stuffed it in
every corner of the complex financial
system when they did that it felt good
i'm getting a 1200 check i'm getting a
boost to unemployment etc but now all of
a sudden the bottom 45 of americans that
hold no assets and didn't participate in
the insane asset appreciation that
occurred by owning a house by having
some sort of stock portfolio crypto
portfolio etc those individuals also
happen to be the people who buy the most
amount of inflationary goods their
groceries is a very large percentage
let's say of their actual monthly
spending and so they're the ones who get
hurt the worst by the inflation that is
now here so if you're in the bottom 45
percent of americans talking about 150
plus million americans
what ends up happening is that you
literally got the public health crisis
then you got the economic slowdown then
you got handed money but that money
ended up actually being a net negative
over the long term because now you're
dealing with insane levels of rent of
grocery prices other assets going up et
cetera and so now as you start to try to
operate your life what you're realizing
is wait a second the politicians who are
mitigating the short-term pain did it at
the expense of the medium to long-term
and so we get in a situation where what
can i do with my wealth well i can't
hold dollars i can't buy treasuries i
can go buy stocks maybe there's some
commodities i can buy or i can buy
cryptocurrencies but if i know that the
stock market is susceptible to the same
exact manipulation the second that they
say ah you know we're going to taper the
stock market's going to crater so okay i
don't want to maybe participate in the
same thing i'm going to seek out
uncorrelated assets where's the
uncorrelated assets well treasury stocks
etc they all move together the most
uncorrelated asset or the most
attractive uncorrelated asset from a
risk return standpoint is bitcoin it's
got a 0.15 correlation level this sharp
ratio is off the chart it's returned
over 400 of the last 12 months and if
you can actually stomach the volatility
in the short term and hold for a long
period of time it's been the single
greatest performing asset over the last
decade so you start to say to yourself
okay well maybe i'm not crazy and i
don't go put a bunch of my net worth
into this or my liquid portfolio but i
probably should own a little bit of it
and that's where you're seeing uh you
know jamie dimon say that uh or i'm
sorry jp morgan say that uh bitcoin has
replaced gold as an inflation hedge
you're seeing bank of america come out
and say hey this entire industry is
going to explode it's not just about the
short-term issues it's also the
long-term tailwinds really starting to
create a massive change in the economy
and psychologically now people have
wrapped their heads around like oh
they're going to continue to manipulate
the economy so let's go ahead and make
sure we're positioned to benefit from